يعد العقار التجريبي الرائد لمرض الزهايمر
المسمى لكلمه نقله طبيه كبيره ان عاشت
الامال في تغيير مسارح علاج المرض لدى
ملايين المرضى وقد اعرب علماء عن ارتياحهم
من النتائج الكامله للمرحله الثالثه من
التجارب السريريه التي بداوها قبل عام
ونصف وشامله الفا و800 من مرضى الزهايمر
في مراحل مبكره من الاصابه فقد اظهرت
النتائج انخفاضا بنسبه
27% من التدهور الادراك لدى المرضى الذين
تلقوا العلاج بعقار لكلمه وتتخذ الشركتان
المصنعتان للعقارب التجريبي اجراءات
الحصول على ترخيص هذا الدواء الجديد
للاستعمال في امريكا واوروبا واليابان
يقول كبير الباحثين في شركه اليابانيه
المصنعه للعقار ان اهميته تكمن في كونه
سميم للقضاء على بروتينات ايميلات بيتا
السامه التي تتسرب في الدماغ وتسبب
الاصابه بمرض الزهايمر
[موسيقى]
قيد المراجعه من قبل اداره الغذاء والدواء
الامريكيه للحصول على موافقه سريعه بموجب
قانون رسوم متعاطي الادويه الموصوفه لذلك
نحن قريبون الان من هذا التاريخ
الاطباء منقسمون حول مدى الاختلاف الذي قد
تحدثه هذه التغييرات للمرضى والاسر فقد
اظهرت النتائج ان العقارات قد يؤدي الى
اثار جانبيه من بينها التورم والنزيف في
الدماغ فيما تدرس اداره الغذاء والدواء في
الولايات المتحده الموافقه المعجله على
العقار ومن المتوقع ان يتخذ القرار في
اوائل يناير واذا تمت الموافقه عليه
فسيكون الثانيه عقار مضاد للاميلاويد في
السوق جميع العلاجات المتاحه لسته ملايين
امريكي مصابين بمرض الزهايمر وملايين في
جميع انحاء العالم تخفف الاعراض مؤقتا فقط
لذا يعد النجاح الذي يمكن ان يحققه هذا
العلاج حاجه ملحها بعد خيبات الامل
المتكرره في البحث عن علاجات افضل لمرض
زعيمر